Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah,
I'm just checking in on you.
I'm taking time out of my day to read
advertising to make a little more scratch,
just to make sure that your
week is going okay. All right.
That's all I'm trying to do here. Jesus
Christ's I hear one more fucking asshole.
Bring up that stupid Michael
Jackson video. I don't know.
What are they going to dig
them up and arrest them?
Okay.
You know and I, I love when anybody did
you see that thing on murder mountain?
Did you see the making of a murderer?
And you go in there and you listen.
You basically you are watching,
you're watching the prosecution's case.
That's not how a case works. Then
you had the defense. All right.
And I think it's kind of fucked up that
you can have something come out about a
dead guy and then everybody's
just going to be like, all right,
now we know definitively that this guy,
he should be allowed to refute
moonwalk out of the grave and be like,
listen,
just because I talk like this and I
like castles and have a giant ice cream
machine in like 17 doors,
that lock or the weight in my
bedroom doesn't even fucking a child.
He should be able to say that
and that because I think he's innocent
a, it's, it's for you and me. Right?
So we get the chance to do that. So some
day, you know, somebody can't just say,
Hey,
I saw this guy with this tally whacker
fucking wagon out of the zipper there.
Right?
You have a chance to defend yourself and
what this new fucking bullshit of the
Internet where they just all do
processes thrown out the fucking window.
The amount of people that I've
seen accused of this me too, Shit.
And then people just immediately go.
Like I always knew he was at Pz Shit.
It's just like you haven't heard,
you've, you've heard an accusation.
But having said that,
having said that,
it makes me feel better about
the suffering of humanity, right?
Cause when you look at
human being suffering,
if you're any sort of a human
being, it bothers you. All right?
But when you see 90% of them on the
Internet going, N***a, you, that guy,
will you be you? Yet at that point
you're like, well maybe I baby,
maybe they don't need that much food.
Oh that was just me, Bill, that
was to meet for the morning.
I am a little bit of a
disappointing morning.
I was going to go fly a helicopter and we
couldn't get the fucking thing started.
This our 22 I don't know what the deal is.
Like if you try to start it before eight,
the magnetos are too cold,
it's too cold outside this time of
year and it just doesn't want to start.
So we've,
we brought a car up to jump in,
which we'd done before and it has
been fine. It looks funny as hell.
But if you just don't look at the fact
that it's a car and it's a helicopter and
you just look at the
engine and you're like, oh,
it's the same fucking so fucking
gas combustion engine. All right.
Same fucking principles here.
Um,
I was really looking forward to flying
and I know what a lot of you guys are
saying like, oh my God, I know why.
There's no fucking way I want to floats
up that I had invited y'all shot. I know,
I know what you'll get in your car that
fucking every time you drive over a
puddle at fucking Jesus in your face,
right?
Coming up through the rusted out
floorboards as you're texting,
driving 90 miles an hour
right down the fucking street.
We'll say 50 drive and 50 looking down
at your fucking phone and there's no
guardrail and there's somebody
driving 50 miles an hour, just one,
not even like three feet up.
You.
Have you ever noticed that when
you drive down the fucking street,
just on a two way street,
like the fact that you're going 50 and
the other guys going 50 and it never
dawns on you like, what is that
guy just fucking swerved over.
We'd both be fucking dead.
It's like you're doing like what the,
the blue angels fly at each other.
The last second they turn away.
You're doing that with complete strangers.
You're not on the radio talking
to each other and every day,
every day somebody on their fucking phone,
they drift over headlight,
the front headlight,
Bam.
Right brain smashing on the inside
of the skull or what do people say?
What do people say? Oh my God,
it's a fucking shape. That's it.
But the next time you go to get in a
car and nobody says like, Hey, I'll go,
maybe you should walk. You're
going to fucking die. Sorry.
I'm trying to preempt everybody
who's going to sit there and fucking
say a bunch of fucking shit
here. Anyways, plowing ahead.
Guess who finally figured out how the
Moto GP website works. Not this guy.
Somebody gave me the Lincoln show me and
then I was able to put in my password
and a so thank you to the,
to the listener who helped me
out and I got to watch that race.
The first one of the Aaron [inaudible]
or a, what do they call k Tar?
The English guys?
Yeah,
like every little fucking word
they say different than us.
It's amazing that we speak the same
language over here. We say Ducati,
they see do catty Oregano or a Ghana,
tomato,
tomato, Qatar, Qatar.
I didn't know that the scene or Qatar,
Qatar is, they think God was saying it.
Um, I don't know when I just
hear shit like that. I really,
and to start to understand how difficult
it is to be a spy, because that's,
that's the shit that gets you caught.
You get the accent down, you know,
you watch a little peaky blinders and
you go over there and next thing you know
you're in Buckingham Palace and you
fucking snooping around to find out what
those balding concert doing in there
with all the goddamn money. Right.
And then all of a sudden, what do you
do? You let it do, you got, uh, uh, Duke,
a Ducati. Forgot how he said it.
A Ducati slip, then that's it,
right?
The queen pushes a button.
You go through the floor right
down to the royal alligators. Um,
yeah,
there's the, I'm gonna tell
you right now, but motor GP,
this is the best fucking racing
that is out there. All right.
On the final lap, the two, the two people,
Andres Divisio so, and Mark Marquez in
first and second place, they change leads.
The delayed changed three
times in the final fucking,
even though I knew it would happen, I
was still up off the couch, you know,
everybody was asleep. So I was
screaming quietly watching it. Um,
and amazing race. Uh, a little
bit of controversy though. Huh?
Do Ducati's the Ducati's they got
this new little piece that they have
underneath the bike that uh,
allegedly is kicking up air to cool
off the rear tire. And these guys,
I guess they chew up their tires big time.
So if he has this little bit
of an advantage, so Davitt CEO.
So one Ducati, one, uh,
the team and immediately
four teams complaint,
which I'm guessing is Honda Suzuki.
Uh,
by the way, how come there's no Harleys
are fucking Indians in the Goddamn race?
Well, what happened? My country,
we started making fucking motorcycles
before all of these constantly.
I gotta look this up.
It's so funny that like,
Indians in like Honda's, it just for
like fat fucks, not Honda's Harleys.
Essentially.
It's for old guys want to sit down.
I like the pegs up nice and
highs my fucking air up my
old fucking ball bag as I
drive down the fucking street and all
the Japanese bikes and the Italian bikes,
they're all for the young guys who
think they're gonna live forever. Right?
Having said all this, having
talked to all this shit, you know,
if I was going to get a bike,
which I would love to, um,
if I wasn't, you know, live in for
somebody else now, but even then,
even before he had a kid,
like, I always liked my legs.
Um, I like my feet pointing
in the direction they're
supposed to be rather than
turned around like I'm fucking like
daffy duck's bill. Every other cartoon.
Um, all right. What the
hell was I looking up?
Oh,
first motorcycle built. All right,
let's see who built it first.
Oh, I got the bad internet.
Huh? Sometimes you get the bad cocaine.
Sometimes you get the bad internet.
What the fuck are you doing here?
Can I only white one first?
Okay.
Fucking motorcycle ever built.
That's going to bring a porno of,
as I said, fucking in it. Come on,
come on. You can load. You can,
you can load if you want to.
You can answer my fucking question.
What is the AH, Jesus fucking
Christ. How much do you have to pay?
How much I am fucking pay nine grand
a month for fucking write the first
motorcycle international
combustion petroleum field
motorcycle was was the damn.
You're right.
Vogle that sounds like German.
It was designed and built
by the German inventors. Ah,
you fucking son's up.
Is there anything worse than when you
think a man did something or America did
it and you find out
they didn't still worst?
I feel like the world's
smiles when that happens.
A motorcycle often called a
bike or a motorbike or a cycle.
I know what that is. Okay. 1,894
Hildebrand and Wolf Mueller became the
first series production motorcycles and
the first to be called a motorcycle in
2014 the three top motorcycle producers
globally by volume or Honda?
Yamaha
and the hero motor corps. I
don't know. It's in India.
Okay.
All right. So we're not the only ones
making motorcycles. Then on in Moto GP.
What is it about like Italians in,
in uh,
Japanese motorcycles that they just
make the fastest ones they got,
they got that on lock down and look
at fucking, um, Japan. They got Honda,
Suzuki and Yamaha.
So what I'm finding out is this
Suzuki's of the best in the corners,
but then the Ducati's and Honda's just
have too many horses when they go down
the straightaway, which is
fucking weird to me. You know,
I guess it would depend on the track
because the one they were riding riding on
head like two long straightaways so when
he sort of fucking ground the dude and
the Suzuki would gain,
he would just lose it every time you
would go by the grand stairs over there.
All right. Enough motorcycle
talk. But I really enjoyed it. Uh,
if you want to jump on board,
there's only like 20 fucking racist.
They're like 22,
2124 laps.
They fly by and you're watching guys
going 200 fucking miles an hour on a
motorcycle, like an eighth of an
inch away from each other. It's done.
I'll tell you,
it's unfucking believable.
I've been given Yannis Pappas Shit.
One of my favorite comics out there.
Absolutely brilliant guy.
But he's like the classic fucking New
Yorker where he did this Instagram post,
right?
And uh,
yeah,
he's like in Philadelphia and he goes,
look at these,
these go and look at the buildings, look
at buildings, buildings. And he goes,
every city looks like New New
York City for a block and a half.
And then the whole thing falls
apart. You know? And I this,
there's something just so fucking
funny about the way New Yorkers travel.
Yeah.
You know,
every place they go to,
if they can't do exactly what the
fuck they can do in New York City,
the place sucks.
It's like you're in Philadelphia.
Why would it look like New York
City? That's why you travel. Oh,
where are all the fuck you'd build thing?
The tristate area is arguably the biggest
collection of meatheads in the United
States of America.
And I,
and this is saying something cause I
grew up in Greater Boston, you know,
and if you want to see
the level of meat had,
just watch a Boston sporting event
when they pay into the crowd.
Okay.
All right. And I'm not talking down.
I know I'm part of the problem.
Yeah.
So I've just been leaving
all these fucking messages.
How New Yorkers just think everything
sucks. This such fucking moron. Oh,
I went to fucking used it.
Right. I mean Houston, Texas.
So I ordered the linguine and the
fuck else. You fucking terrible.
Yeah.
Okay. Good. Good Italian. And use the
Texas. Why didn't you get the barbecue?
You dumb.
Fuck.
Okay.
Why don't you get some Tex Mex
[inaudible] I went to buffalo,
right.
I fucking went to the buffalo wild
wings and fucking wigs. I tag good
fucking morons. They are fucking
morons. It, you know what's funny?
I um, I went to the Brody
Memorial, right? I can't remember.
I talked about this on Monday.
I still can't get over this.
This guy was eulogizing is that
the right word? Brody Stevens.
And he somehow was able
to trash Boston twice.
It is fucking eulogy. It was one of the
high points of it cause it was, you know,
it was really uplifting,
but it was sad.
But it was kind of funny to see that New
York fans are that fucking annoyed that
we won some championships finally,
you know,
finally won a couple, you know, and that,
that it's bothering them so much that
they're now reduced to making fun of our
skyline.
Uh,
and that's stupid shit that ESPN came
up with where they would like say that
Boston had an inferiority complex is one
of my favorite with New York is one of
my favorite thing ever. I don't have
the heart to tell New York is that like,
yeah, we don't even, we
didn't even know that.
We didn't know what the
fuck it looked like.
He'd given us too much
credit. Um, I want to say,
I already talked about this on Monday,
but you know,
like whenever they
fucking show New England,
whenever there's a game in New England,
they're always showing
some sort of foliage. Uh,
something about the revolutionary war
and then somebody is eating a fucking
oyster is something and it's just like,
that's really, that's, that's not a good,
uh, that's not a good indication
of what's going on. Yeah,
yeah,
yeah. So somebody in a dive bar with a
beer and a fucking shot that, yeah, maybe,
and don't,
don't go to the bull and finch,
that stupid fucking cheers thing or
whatever the hell it is. Um, anyways,
having said that to all the New York is
listening, I absolutely love your city.
I love the people. I just don't
like the Yankees. That's it.
Everything else about it.
I absolutely love having said that.
I love Philadelphia too.
I enjoy Washington DC.
Milwaukee is one of my favorite cities.
I don't fucking,
cause when I go there I don't
try to get fuck it. Don't,
let's get some fucking killer fucking
clam chowder is shocked in Green Bay job.
MMM
Dude. I, I fought in, I go, I go
to fucking Argentina. Right dude,
I'm fucking down yet. And I, and I say
to guy, can I get a fucking Sam Adams?
[inaudible] got an email
she had no Sam Adams.
Yeah.
So I told this fucking place sucks.
MMM.
Did anybody else,
do you have any stories like that?
I shouldn't really just blame New Yorkers,
but does anybody else have like,
cause I think country people are like
that too, where they just kind of look
to [inaudible] y'all deal. There's
all these broken people out here, man.
You give me the wild open
spices mile property.
Get me a four wheeler and a good woman
who does now the self esteem to walk off.
Right. She knows I'll fucking club or
over the head and feed her to my pigs.
I've done it before.
She knows it.
We never talk about it.
But she knows that she goes out
when she goes to feed the pig.
She sees a couple of thugs hanging
on a nail. She knows what that means.
I told her I've been married
twice before she gets it.
MMM.
Yeah. People, the purpose of traveling
is, is, is the when in Rome, right?
When in Rome do as the Romans do.
That's what you do. All right.
You fucking go over there. Do you go over
to fucking, you know, uh, the UK, right?
Premiere League.
See,
get yourself a fucking pint in a
scarf and start singing some socks.
All right.
Okay.
You know,
pull a very busy,
like an in a study and you talked to some
90 year old woman over there, you know,
in blazing fast English. Go in like, Hey,
do you know where we can watch
the NFL divisional round playoffs?
Yeah.
You know what it is? I think
about New Yorkers, they've just,
they've just some too many fucking
songs about your city and then all these
meatheads who really didn't
do that well in school,
they think they're part of the success
rather than the digits background in the
movie. Um, as I've always said,
Frank Sinatra was bridging
tunnel.
He was a Jersey guy,
four x, and he lives in nowhere. There's
no buildings and fucking place sucks.
Yeah.
Um, alright. Plowing ahead here. Uh,
I did some stand up the other night,
first time since Royal Albert Hall.
I had a good time trying out new shit.
Just like, just nothing. I got nothing.
So I'm going to go down to the comedy
store possibly this weekend. Well,
maybe not this week and maybe next
weekend and I'm just gonna fucking,
I'm just going to do
20 minutes of new shit.
I'm just going to have like four or five,
six subjects written down and I'm going
on stage and I'm just going to stand
there and fucking take it.
Um,
and it's one of my favorite
things in the world to do. Um,
I was just listening to Brody special,
the one that he has on fucking
iTunes and uh, I just, I don't know,
just listening to that guy plowing through
this, just one of my favorite things.
Definitely gonna miss that guy. Um, but
it was an incredible memorial service,
which I really would think that I talked
about it on Monday. I believe I did.
I just kept no fucking short term memory.
So anyways,
Hayden was funny was
right before I started,
I asked my wife if she could just go
talk in the other room because she was
talking, she had a phone on speaker
and you know, I'm just recording.
Just didn't want that shit in
the background at all. My God,
the fucking look she gave
me. It's unbelief. Anal.
She's asking me to do shit all
the fucking time. Can you go here?
Can you pick up this? Can you do
this? Can you do that? I'll ask to do,
it was just move down one room,
close the door.
She just looked at me cause I know what
she's going to say. You fucking talk.
So fucking lad. When you then effecting
third get get the [inaudible],
you know it's always, it always
comes back. Always come back.
Hey de Rosa sent me some,
I guess they got this new fucking
Charlie Manson movie that's coming out,
whether they're trying to make the women
that Charlie convinced to kill those
people.
Victims.
Okay,
I don't give a fuck if
you're a victim or not.
If you are dumb enough that you let
some fucking psycho look in Jesus,
talk you into murdering a pregnant
woman and then trying to cut the
baby out. Yeah, you shouldn't
be walking around in society.
This is the new fucking thing.
The new fucking thing now is to go back
in time and find a bunch of selfish cons
and then somehow blame it on guys.
And in order to started with it
started with that stupid movie monster.
Yeah.
Well that fucking loan at tech was a
serial killer and I'm watching the movie
and they're trying to make me feel guilty.
Like I'm, I'm, I'm part of the problem.
I'm the reason why she became one.
I saw the Jeffrey Dahmer movie.
They didn't do that.
They just like,
this guy's out of his fucking
mind and he's eaten people.
Um, I don't know, but it's a
woman. There has to be a reason.
Maybe she just came out of the womb
a complete fucking psycho. Right?
Maybe that's what it was.
I don't fucking know.
I think they tried to like find some
sort of trajectory in the madness of
Jeffrey Dahmer, but at no
point did they blame women. Um,
although in fairness to though
they,
um,
okay.
Who's that guy? That Ed Game Guy,
that guy from fucking Wisconsin. Um,
they did try to s they did say that his
mother fucked him up. So I don't know.
Maybe I'm just being a baby,
you know,
maybe I should have moved
to a one room over. Is that,
is that what I should've done?
Um, all right. So as I mentioned,
the Bruins lost two in a row, two in a
row, hoping to get back on track here.
Um, I'm going to the fucking Gad and
dreams April 2nd, everybody. April 2nd.
I'm doing the garden of dreams with,
uh,
John Stewart.
Oh, this is in New York City by the way.
Oh my God. They read is unbelievable.
It's so much nicer than a Rita's
another fucking shit. Cities
I'm doing. It's Jerry Seinfeld. Jon
Stewart, Elijah Schlesinger. You're okay.
Uh,
who else? Who else? Who
else? I forget who else.
Those are the names that I remember.
Oh, and yours truly. How could I forget?
Lovely mate.
Lovely baldy that embolding balled me.
Um, that's the name of my one show.
One man show. Lovely balled me.
I've chosen me.
I've decided to ignore all the advertising
did sing that I'm not good enough and
to say that I am good enough.
How fragile is your fucking psyche
that you fucking sit there looking at
advertising and it fucks with you to that
level that you're walking out behind a
fucking Papa John's throwing up into
a handicapped parking spot right now.
I know what you think of bill.
Why would you suggest that Papa John's
puts the handicap parking behind?
I've never eaten it.
Papa John's. All right.
Yeah,
I like Papa Ginos Nice fucking Italian.
I didn't want some guy named John
Making my goddamned pizza. All right.
I want someone who can get a fucking tank.
That's something that
Burns in fucking April. Um,
what was I talking about?
The I've just, yeah, I mean,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
First of all,
the arrogance of you that you look at
a Victoria's secret model and you feel
like you have to compete with that.
First of all,
you can't any more than I
can compete with a Brad Pitt.
So what is the fucking problem?
And the second of all,
when's the last time you saw a Victoria's
secret model walk into the bar that
you're drinking at?
All right.
You fucking regular looking person.
You're an irregular looking person bar,
you know with me and the second
and eight walks in the room,
everybody fucking turns like,
like Bo Derek just came
walking in and that movie 10
Hollywood just create season.
Possible Standard. Yes. It's a movie.
I don't understand. Like I like when
they do this reboot Buddha top gun.
I'm not going to feel like I need to
learn how to fly a fucking fat to wherever
the fuck they're flying. Was it f 19?
[inaudible] are they up to the 19?
What are they up to now?
Let's see.
Uh,
you as a top fighter jet.
All right.
What do we got here?
Don't even fucking tell me. It's
called this the sue [inaudible] sue 57.
Is it made in Japan?
Do we make anything here?
Please tell me.
An Asian American came up with that and
they make this an please for the love of
God.
Do you guys have fucked up?
That was if all our fighter jets are
made in Japan and then we have beef with
them again and it's like,
hey man, can you keep making,
making this jet so like we can get you
back for bombing the other part of Hawaii
now, uh, top 10 best
fighter jets in the world.
The top seven US fighter jets. I'll
come. They're not, not doing the, uh,
the f anymore.
The JTTF 22.
Dude, I'm so old. I remember,
I remember the [inaudible],
they have 16 was the bump and I remember
a two 40 z before the two 80 z before
the 300.
All right.
I remember the f 100.
I don't,
who's the F-150 in f two 50.
I just needed another example was another
one where they just kept going up the
Mazda rx seven.
What are they up to nine.
I love how they think.
They say they don't start it.
One like Jordan's like the sneakers,
you know, then was a Jordan twos,
Jordan threes. They started
like seven or a hundred.
Um, if you wonder what the
fuck I'm talking about. I
don't, I don't know either.
All right. I have no idea.
But anyways, I'm doing the gap
dreams on, uh, April 2nd.
It's in the, uh, it's the
theater at Madison Square Garden.
As I mentioned on Monday, this is where
Eddie Murphy did, uh, the raw special.
So I always think about that.
So I will be there and I'm also the day
before I'm going to go try to go to a
Brooklyn Nets game.
Now,
I haven't gone to a pro game in a minute
as far as checking another one off the
list and I'd forgotten.
I only need like six more teams and I've
been to a home game of every protein in
all four fucking sports.
Now there's a very select few of you
that thinks that's awesome and that's who
I'm talking to right now.
The rest of you could just fucking zone
out because this part of the podcast,
it's not about you
any more than than an
average looking woman.
It has to feel intimidated because you
know there's another Cindy Crawford
coming along,
her is now going to make a whole other
generation of people not feel pretty
enough and I got to tell
you something there.
There is a beauty in coming
to the realization that you,
you aren't pretty enough.
And just embracing that and
just being like, you know what?
I'm going to be the coolest six
that walks into this bar tonight.
It's all right being a sixth. Then
you just add add to it, you know,
telecom, couple of jokes, learn how
to juggle. You know what I mean?
It's like you ever see
somebody when they get a three,
a Chrysler 300 and they try,
they try to make it look like a Bentley.
That's what you do.
But at no point do you actually say that
you're a fucking Bentley or do you get
mad that somebody is making a Bentley?
Is any of that makes sense?
I don't fucking know.
Um,
this is usually the point here
when I would read some advertising,
but I didn't get any so far.
I wonder why.
Probably because I shit on every
goddamn one of them. You know,
and they fucking sensitive. Think these
women today have fucking sensitive.
Do you think these millennials
get their feelings hurt? See,
these fucking advertising companies
can't say a goddamn thing.
Um,
oh, I do have a read. Here we go.
Dollar Shave Club Jayode has
everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best.
And you never have to go to a Stila.
That's because they delivered everything
you need right to your front door.
You Lazy Bastard and they keep
you fully stocked and what you,
what you use so you don't run out.
Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club has everything
you need to get ready.
They have you covered from head to toe
for your hair, your skin, your face,
you name it, they got it.
Deodorant free attained.
They have this new program where they
automatically keep it stocked up on
products you use.
You determine what you want when you
want it and shows right up your door from
once a month to once every six
months or however you want to do it.
Plus they're handsome discount. The
more you buy, the more you save.
And Right now dollar shave club has a
bunch of status sets you can try for just
five bucks, like their oral
care kit. Ladies after that,
the restock box ships regular sized
products@regularpricegetsyoustatussetforjustfivedollarsrightnowatdollarshaveclub.com
slash burr. That's dollar
shave club.com/bar.
So,
so here we are.
Okay.
And it's now time to talk about,
yeah,
soccer,
I guess Liverpool,
my adopted team is still down to
point to those men. City cuts.
All right. What? Their, uh, wait, wait.
Did they get their money from
somebody told me, God damn
it, it's not Saudi Arabia
is it? You know, did they get it from air?
Emirates does that when they
get it from the airline.
Okay.
Throw some of their first class fucking
ticket money at them. I don't remember.
Anyways, they're down a point that
down a point and they've got a game.
Liverpool's got a game on Monday.
They pay full M is, I would say,
so they're probably full hand. Boom. You
go buy Bulla Wall on Saint Patty's Day.
All Saint Paddy's Day you got to get out
there where you're green plastic cat.
You know,
where's my Hashtag on that
day where I get offended?
Everybody going at agreed
alligator and allowing net goes,
yeah,
yeah. Everyone's getting shit for you.
Don't realize how fucked up that is.
You know how funny it is?
Irish people are part Irish people.
They go out and they just like,
there's no other fucking holiday.
You know where people go out in,
in people who are that nationality
literally go out and do the most
like negative stereotype of themselves.
You know,
black history month, everybody's
on their best behavior, right?
Jewish holidays, everybody's
fucking Schilling. Saint
Patty's Day. What happens I,
everybody goes out and gets
drunk in the fucking street.
Dresses like a Leprechaun and passes
out in the gutter. That's what happens,
right? Fucking corn, beef
sandwich. Fucking hanging out
of the side of your mouth.
Well, that's what I always
hated about that holiday.
It's like we're one of the prides of
the Irish is not only do you drink,
you can handle your fucking liquor.
Don't, but don't. Can you guys just don't.
Just don't make a messy yourself.
Fucking sitting there drinking green beer.
The fuck are you doing?
Oh Shit.
Odell Beckham Jr goes from the
giants to the Cleveland browns.
Cleveland Brown fans beside themselves
can't believe their good fortune.
Now they got out, they got that
kid there. What's his face there?
They got the quarterback. I just spaced
on his name. Baker Mayfield, right?
He's got a little bit of a swagger. He
likes talking a little bit of Shit, right?
He likes doing something
and doing a little dance in
front of the fucking crowd.
Now he's got a wide
receiver. Right. So what's,
this might work if they have like an
Al Davis old school sort of thing.
Because this reminds me of
what the Raiders used to do,
where they would take the fucking people.
Everybody said don't take,
are the outcasts from other teams.
And then they would go in there.
Everybody would just be themselves
and they would have a good time.
I hope it works out for the browns. My
Gut says, I can't say that it won't.
It just all depends on the coach.
The personality.
Like that's a good rex Ryan team.
Cause then he's talking shit. Oh,
Dell's talking shit. Baker's
doing what the fuck he does. Uh,
but it's definitely going to be exciting.
But I actually think,
I think it was a good move for the giants.
He didn't kind of fit into their,
they have vibe defensive
minded organization.
You look at Eli shows up, he's got Khakis
on, he tucks his shirt in. I mean that's,
that's what the giants, I guess
have become, I don't know,
you listened to some of those lt
stories. Oh, Dosha fit right in. But, um,
I dunno, it was a big move and I don't,
I don't think they had to give all,
give up too much for the guy and they got
a lot of draft picks, see what they do.
And uh,
I've gotten a couple of friends of mine
that a Cleveland Brown fans and they're
all saying that GM knows what he's doing.
So who knows?
Okay.
The only thing I need out of Cleveland
fans is to stop calling you stupid city.
The land, the land. Ugh.
Fucking Midwest people.
The land,
the Berg,
did they call Cincinnati the natty.
Okay.
Get on the bus.
You're in Columbus.
You get it the day.
Welcome to the day.
Is that what they say? Dayton? Huh? Um,
all right. Sorry. I'm being a cunt, but
it's what I do. All right. That's it.
I'm going to be,
uh,
out and about in La doing some
spots bombing this weekend.
Uh, probably be down the store on Friday.
That's the deal. All right, so go Bruins,
go Celtics.
Baseball is starting up.
A interesting stat here,
man.
This is something that on the
success of the New York Yankees,
do you realize the New York
Yankees is so fucking successful?
That sense they got babe Ruth all right.
From the 1920s to this decade,
they've only gone one decade
where they didn't win a war,
at least one world series. And
that was the 1980s. And even still,
they went to a world series in
[inaudible] 81 in lost. Right.
If they don't win this year,
this'll be the first time that that's
the only second time this has happened
since women were allowed to vote.
Okay.
Which was another huge,
huge fucking mistake by this country.
Okay.
You should have kept those fucking
broads in the kitchen. No. Um,
I think it's great that
they can talk more.
Um,
anyways.
Am I the only one who's like not
looking forward to this next election,
presidential election? I
just, I just don't see this.
I just didn't see it being ever repeat
of a few years ago and it's just going to
be a fucking train wreck.
MMM.
Until you get that cancer
out of the locker room.
I just don't know what it's
going to be. I, if I, you know,
if I was running for president
on the democratic side,
what I would learn how to do
is talk some shit. All right?
Stop trying to talk about issues.
What you need to do is you need
to go in there and you need,
you need to make fun of his hair.
Make Fun of that to pay.
Make Fun of his fucking big motherly hips.
You gotta you gotta go after him
like that. All right? Why is,
why is your face orange and
underneath your eyes, his ghost white?
Do you have a tanning bed?
Is that some sort of cream that you
put under your eyes for puffiness?
That's what you do.
Do not go up there and try to talk policy
and interrupt the shit out of them.
Just do what he does.
Completely ignore all the fucking rules.
And then when you get called on it
just act like a victim. All right?
That's what it's going to be. This is what
politics is fucking become. [inaudible]
MMM.
I mean I'm acting like it was on the
up and up before that. But uh, I dunno.
We shall see. Although I do have to
give Trump some props ground in that,
that airplane,
he did do that.
He did try to pull the troops
out of Syria. You saw the
Democrats and Republican.
Oh whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Don't do that.
You bite the hand that
feeds by net corporate cash.
I'll spill it out of their pockets.
And you watch all you ladies out
there loving your girl there.
The 29 year old check you
watch you fucking well how
soon before she gets a book
deal, how sue before, she's
somehow a multimillionaire,
only making 150 200 grand a year,
but she has a vagina so Saudi you,
so you should vote for it, right?
That should make you feel good. All
right, that was a country way to end,
but that's how it's going to happen.
Enjoy the music.
And there'll be another half hour of a
greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon,
just before Monday,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from
earlier this year or years before.
And I don't fuck it.
All right.
Have a great weekend. You cuts go
Liverpool. I'll see you on Monday.
[inaudible] Canadian streetlight steps.
You and me.
They give me a hug.
He's underneath to window
shooting,
you know, and that show
and I, Naomi Campbell,
she's like 52 and she's still in sexy.
So it was like Tyra got
a lot of years to go day.
Who did we see walking away
from that hotel that day? Oh,
I Cheryl t Cheryl Tiegs. They're
looking good. That time is a bitch, man.
Really is a bitch. No, a realist change.
Minimum. Forgot doing.
I think you got a bit of a fetish known
you for awhile and older white women and
he picks a bag with Hillary Clinton,
Iowa.
My favorite number one is a Carly Simon.
I will still pop each time and
I don't know why. I know why.
Everybody got their fucking
fetishes album cover alone,
which she was on all fours. Oh Wow. That
big mouth. Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
John Brockman that pitches by the way,
a lot of people backed us up on that one.
Wow. Yeah. Backyard. A lot of people
were calling him and saying, Lord, Chuck,
celebrity pop up.
Moving back though.
We saw Cheryl Tiegs leaving the
Donald Trump pros. Yeah, Cheryl Tiegs.
We had the great seats from Vos. Well,
yeah, probably fairly in the building.
Thanks Richard. I got your checklist
for the Trump roast section. Oh,
it's going to be [inaudible] we,
we were behind a monitor that was
showing the rows behind it on the second
floor. Dude, everyone's going in the main
ballroom and we handed our tickets like,
oh, we're going to be hobnobbing with the,
the top celebrities in New York. Right.
All of a sudden the usher, it looks
at our tickets and goes, Oh God,
take that elevator. But the,
and then you're thinking,
all right, well, you
know, it's an elevator.
You ever see a roast with as an upstairs?
It's always, it's the, the day is,
and the tables upstairs that are roasts.
So at first we're like, all right,
well we'll follow all the other people
that have seats in that area. No,
there were maybe another 20 people that
had Seattle area and we sit down and
then I,
I my seat stunk.
I had him stand up and look over
this video screen to see anything.
I couldn't tell who was up at the,
they were tying,
everybody gets in the elevators
like holding cable and shit. Yeah,
that's what it was. They
were all tech guys. Gaffers,
they are heading for the
fucking mixing board.
So we're heading for the
walkways high above. So we leave.
The roasts were walking back
towards the station and uh,
we were right behind Cheryl Tiegs and
her white old Sechi has like how bad did
it looked at? I mean,
here's what I'm saying,
for an old old lady,
she probably isn't that bad.
But when you compare her to the Cheryl
Tiegs poster that was on everybody's wall
with the netting that she was just
wearing a net and her nipples were poking
through. I mean, you wouldn't fuck
Sophia Loren. No, just cause she exists.
60 something
ran.
I don't gotta be just a
glimpse of just young.
So phase one trial, half a pussy
lip, paint, nothing out there.
Believe me.
And when you see these people out,
remember they are looking
their absolute best.
This is the best they can possibly look.
How old is shared with Teagues?
50 got to bed.
She's gotta be old manner in her fifth
phase five and she's gonna Finish and no
red beam and sexuality. She's not drunk.
I didn't see any redeeming sexuality.
I saw an older woman
that you look at and go,
all right, she's, you know,
an older woman that doesn't look
like she's ready to fall apart.
What do you know the old broad w women
like who continue to dye their hair like
that? It becomes like a fucking
birds nest itself right out there.
That also as you get into like you,
you get into like your sixties
it's like the smell of rotten.
If you're attending deaths. Study
started having that old person's smell.
So when you see the top of their head,
because then it gets to what you taught
and you see that you see right through
that penny hair. It's like
fucking white cotton candy, hair,
scalp price at a Lowe's.
They'd fucking box in the back of her
hand and she jerking you off. Yes,
you got it. You got a fucking old Sophia
Loren and fucking movie on the TV.
Try not to look at the, what happened
to that rod? Don't you got back up?
Oh Shit. Bitch. Close your eyes.
Close Your eyes
opened up an ark of the covenant in front
of that Bitch. Right on man. No, she, she,
she looks like you know a nice older lady.
But you know you have a yeah,
just against, you're just against old
bitches. I can feel it. You know what?
I disagree with that.
It's not that I, I went,
it's the hottest old bits you could test
it cause he's comparative to the memory
has what? It is hot. I'm,
I'm remembering what she looked like.
Oh,
who's the hottest obits
that's asking a good question.
I'm trying to stay knew her was
because she was a sex symbol.
So already there your old
bitch. I know. And, and,
and here's is the criteria is I had
Sawyer. It's not one that became,
that used to be hot, super hot and
just maintained it. But like, oh wow.
She used to wait. She,
she used to be super hot,
but now she's an old bitch like Cheryl
Tiegs. But she's still like, you know
what's up? God knows
now, motherfucker now,
not when she was old in 80.
Remember talk was still young.
Dukey makeup I'm talking about right
this second. She's a bad bitch.
God Damn least old enough.
Uh,
all you guys say was he couldn't go
back to the 70s and think who do,
who did I want to fuck back then?
Trying to think, but they were all,
I never wanted to pack her mom's back
then ever a hot looking and on bitch that
you had all bag right now. Pam
Grier, Pam Greer, I got, Oh,
a Jessica Simpson.
Hold size 22 years old. See I took the
bed and went the other way. I can write,
I think I'm trying,
I'm going through like old seventies
TV show kind of things cause I may not
there 80 minutes or area in Roscoe. It
seemed like a filthy lucre. Marion Ross,
the mother from happy days.
I like to Karen grassle
famils house on the prairie,
the mother from little house,
Barry Ross was a bit of a whore.
While there's always, yeah, there's always
answered. Yeah, that is hot as shit.
Something her and Fonzie going to go.
No.
Talk about my mom that there's
always ads. Mom, shut up Anthony.
His mother's heart.
Yeah.
Never talk about my mom like
that just takes care of herself.
But you know, she's no spring
chicken. That's what you guys love.
Real awkward moment. I have with a
good friend of mine, the other daily,
he came to town, I took her to a Knicks
game. Right? He's sitting there, right?
And I go, uh, and he, he's
talking about my little sister.
He goes, well, how, how, uh,
how old? How old is she now? Huh? And I'm
like, uh, he is she in high school yet?
I go, dude, if you can believe that
she's graduating high school. He goes,
good Lord. We're getting old. Like,
yeah, you should see it. I mean,
she knows beautiful girl.
And he goes, he goes, well,
the apple doesn't fall
too far from the tree.
Your mother was always really attractive,
but it was just kind of silenced,
so used to jerk off to my mom.
That's great. Great to know. Yeah.
You got to fill in the blank
and that the RBS bridge to,
yeah. Lynda Carter. Pat Benatar,
Katar, Lynda Carter. Now Lynda Carter.
Now Linda fucking,
yes.
Let me say something I want into Lynda
Carter when she was wonder woman else.
Dad Bitch from Buck Rogers
and 20 for the Aaron Gray.
She was very hot during that time.
Now God, she's still a hotbed.
She's dumped on my Suzanne Summers,
but she got that carved up
faced I shit is really old man.
Let's go to a gym in Waco.
Jim. She kept those tapes.
Every time I see her,
I hated those fucking big bloomer
panty thing she wore and they didn't
[inaudible] Victoria's secrets by now.
Big Bloom.
My bitch with those boots, not, I
was never into higher even as a kid,
like when she was wonder woman.
She was motherly looking.
How about Lani and she's just,
she's just,
she's,
when I was fucking terrified when I
was 10 I was into 10 year old girls.
When I was 12 I was it to 12 year
old girls, 1414 year old girls.
That's how I went.
I was never like 14
into 38 year old women.
I never found them attractive. They were
like moms, so whatever your name is,
your whatever.
My age was up until 15 and then
it was always just 15 year olds.
So they just did, he just made, okay,
so 14 you weren't into 28 year olds.
Now that means though,
so let's double it.
He's not into something double
his age shows aunties by eight.
So how old was show gotta be 122 years.
I was trying to back you into that corner.
I know
Derek is coming. Oh Derrick.
Still hot. Bo. Derek now. Okay.
If you got to point out a hotter, older
woman. All right, I'll give it to Bo.
Derek.
She still looks good so it doesn't look
like she's trying to keep yourself young
with fucking surgery and chip.
There's nothing worse than these duck
billed fucking old broads walking around
[inaudible] I rejected the lips
thinking it looks good, ladies.
You Look Freakish. You look like
ducks. It's creepy. They talk like,
God, please got a pedicure
appointment for next week. One out.
Oh, there's a creepy, I don't
like that. Look at all it is.
[inaudible]
we'll assume that any
man
finds a streetlight
steps out of the shade is
you and me?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].